well in a little over 27 hours we're
going to be no we're going to know who
is the new leader of the conservative
party and the prime minister of the
united kingdom it's been a long and
grueling contest we've had hours of
hosting social media spats policy routes
stitching the conservative party back
together again is not going to be easy
well our next guest knows better than
most how rishi sunik and liz trust are
going to be feeling today uh he lost in
2005 to uh david cameron hate to remind
you of that
david davis thank you very much for
being uh with us
well it looks pretty certain doesn't it
that liz trust will be the next leader
of your party how do you think she's
going to get on it looks like it looks
likely i mean we're not we're not sure
until we see the ballots of course and
it's a really difficult uh electorate to
uh to censor but the but how's well look
she faces probably the second most
difficult
uh brief uh in their post-war prime
ministers i mean the only person with a
worse brief coming in was margaret
thatcher i think the country was
bankrupt and all sorts of other problems
but
so she's got this huge set of problems
obviously the cost of living crisis
backing off from ukraine
and also within that the energy crisis
really really difficult i actually don't
think
any of the candidates not one of them
going through it really knows quite how
big this is going to be it's going to be
on a par with the furlough scheme in
terms it's going to be tens of billions
of costs it's going to be rewriting
markets it's going to be intervening and
that's what you think should happen
that's what should happen that's where
it has to happen i mean yeah you
we worry about and we talk a lot in
politics about the vulnerable of course
they are the most important to deal with
but also small businesses and businesses
generally employment the whole economy
is going to take a shock if you can sort
it out so so that's got to be done and
that's huge and it will it'll involve to
some extent putting your ideologies on
one side you know you know we're all
free marketeers we're all low tax
enthusiasts i mean me more than most i
guess um but we're gonna have to think
well actually for this next 12 months go
through something different so you've
got that coming and then a whole pack of
other things behind it on the tax cuts
i'm interested because as you say you
know you are someone who ideology
ideologically like the idea of tax cuts
and believe in low taxes
liz trust of course has talked a lot
about low taxes as the way forward but
do you think that actually that is not
the right thing to do
in the short to medium term because the
quantity well i mean the first thing to
understand if we talk about tax cuts
what she's talking about is cancelling
tax increases that's the first thing and
this is quite an important difference
i'm not too worried about the the
national insurance cancellation actually
that will now end up given the way that
rishi amended it as being a net tax cut
because he's taken 70 percent out of
people out of it
the corporation tax i think they're
going to think quite hard about actually
um i'm
again i'd like a low uh headline tax but
these days vast amounts of corporate
money goes to buying back shares and
propping up their own share price and so
on i've got to think about how that
works so so there's quite a lot to be
done there but in principle uh it's the
right direction but she's gonna find
balance in the books really difficult if
i'm right
about the cost of the energy crisis
tens upon tens of billions of pounds in
the short not in the long term but in
the short term uh and you add to that
the necessary increase in defense cost
because ukraine you had to have that
necessary increase in in nhs costs it's
going to be quite difficult to make the
books balance and the worst outcome
is as it were to give low taxes a bad
name by going down a route which leads
to an increase in uh in interest costs
massive increases in people's mortgages
and or a decline in the pound the
pound's been going down systematically
over the over the last year or so if it
drops off a cliff then we're going to
have more inflation so that it's it's a
really really difficult balancing job
it's not for nothing that margaret
thatcher actually put taxes up earlier
in her
in her years now i don't think that's
the right thing to do either but the but
it's difficult one point i'm making is a
knife edge calculation she has to make i
mean actually say it is difficult it's a
very difficult outlook it's going to be
a bumpy road whoever ends up winning uh
tomorrow
are you can you say 100 certainty that
whoever wins tomorrow assuming it's liz
trust will lead the conservative party
into the next election
it's that's only two years away so it's
a 90 something percent probability but
more more more more
pressing than that in a way is what you
sort of intimated when you introduced me
and and that is that there is a real
risk the party will sort of feel divided
yeah you know um and that means if
that's the case we won't win the next
election uh and so it's gonna be really
important that she
pulls people in so would you what do you
think that the cabinet needs to involve
different people from different factions
of the past
would you like to see russia soon for
the job i would i mean look the greatest
mistake that boris johnson made i mean
there were a few but right back at the
beginning and it sort of slightly
shocked me was the fact that he
basically created a cabinet of loyalists
you know it wasn't a meritocratic
cabinet it wasn't the best people you
know uh jeremy hunt was offered to
demotion so obviously didn't take it
others like liam fox or indeed penny
morton wasn't in cabinet you know which
absolutely justified the place uh and
there were other i could give you a list
of half a dozen who should have been
there and who might have
talked to him and talked him out of some
of the silly things he did ranging from
some of the mistakes on kobe through to
the mistakes on hand in the house and
looking at the people who were talked
about as being in the next liz trust
cabinet are you worried she was going to
make that absolutely i think i think
that look it's it's always tempting you
know if you're going to win this sort of
thing you've had people been around you
since the beginning you want to you want
to be loyal to them and so on but
actually your your loyalty is to a
bigger entity your loyalties to the
country and the party and that's hard
that's hard to do on the first day so
what i think should brace yourself and
do it what kind of job do you think
russia sue now for example should be
offered what you could offering foreign
secretary yeah he'd do that very well
she won't want to put him in back in as
chancellor because they have very
different views on that and that's
public um i mean something very senior
so in top half doesn't anyway do you
think that she might be tempted to call
an early election
uh no actually
everybody talks about it the
oppositional court always called for it
as well
um but no i mean we've got an 80
majority you know um there was a
suggestion when boris was
going out as it were that he might call
an election
and the suggestion came right back from
the palace and we may not grant one you
know the the conditions for an election
are you need to have one to deliver a
majority out of commons there is not
that need at the moment and finally on
boris johnson there are rumors
that he could be persuaded to come back
um well rumors probably coming from
boris johnson's camp i i i dismissed
most of this stuff about a a resurgence
of boris boris has got some really tough
times in the next few months what with
the privileges committee and so on um
and people i mean you know if he if he
had not gone because of the resignation
whatever it was 50 ministers the very
next week the party would have uh passed
about to no confidence in him that's why
that will happen we forget that that he
lost the confidence in the party and i
don't think he'll get that back in a
hurry okay thank you very much indeed
david davis